from a certain perspective it looks as
if there is a bubble around
cyber security globally and definitely
in israel
but i fully agree with you that the need
for advanced cyber security
is here to stay and definitely is going
to intensify
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford if you're into cyber you're
gonna love this one
meet nathan shukhami a managing partner
at hyperwise ventures
an israeli venture capital that leads
seed investments in the cyber security
and enterprise software domains
he co-founded and led as a ceo centrigo
inc
acquired by mcafee where he became vp
database security
nathan later co-founded hyper-wise
security acquired by checkpoint software
technologies where he became vp of
emerging products
nathan shahami good morning how are you
good morning michael um
everything is well hopefully it's the
same with you
excited to be here i'm excited to have
you here
an expert in cyber security both as an
entrepreneur but also as a venture
capital investor
yes you you're you've seen both ends and
obviously you know
from the start of nation in the world of
cyber security and we're just seeing the
industry
boom more and more and while uh i've had
some
interesting discussions with uh fellow
friends and researchers about maybe this
is just you know one big bubble that is
gonna burst
and i really don't think it will and i
think that you know we're in it for the
long run
and the more the technology advances the
more we're gonna have this cat and mouse
game
and which obviously keeps it interesting
given that we're the sort of the cat and
and the red team is the mouse and so
what i'm really
excited to talk to you about is your
expertise in the world of cyber security
your entrepreneurial journey your
investment thesis but also
you know the way that now you see you
know the industry from the side and
and what what have been your
observations over you know years of
experience and watching
hundreds if not thousands of of young
entrepreneurs go through that
so nathan get us started tell me a
little bit about who you are and a
little bit about your journey
um so
indeed throughout my professional career
i had multiple experiences so i
definitely consider myself to be blessed
from that perspective
uh i started my professional career like
many others especially in the
israeli high tech and cyber security
industry
by serving almost 11 years with
8200 fulfilling multiple
multiple roles having a very
exciting career there then for a short
period of time i was
seriously considering developing a legal
career
so i was uh i was very technical
yeah even though i was very technical
in my background i was seriously
considering studying math
and even up until today this is
definitely a soaring point
but nevertheless i chose to um study
laws i had a
first and second degree in commercial
law from the
tel aviv university i was i did my
internship in
jacob weinroth law firm and then in the
israeli supreme court
i was even touched teaching contracts in
the tel aviv
university for three years but then
i was lucky and i got a proposal from a
guy that they used to serve with me
with the 8200 that in the early 90s has
established a startup and he
gave me a proposal that i couldn't
refuse and
in the mid 90s i decided to join a
startup by the name of enigma
which was not a cyber security startup
despite the name
and i was i worked for enigma for
nine and a half years primarily as a
sales manager as a vp sales
living for four years in boston and then
moving to europe and
becoming vp cells europe for four years
out of munich
but then in 2006
i met a brilliant technical entrepreneur
by the name of slavik markovic
who later became the ceo of the misto
and
together we have established a cyber
security startup by the name of centrigo
focusing on database security we moved
to the bay area in 2008
we crossed the horrible crisis of the
subprime crisis the meltdown in 2008
literally three months after we both
relocated to the bay area
tough times i have to say nathan funny
anecdote
is that slavic was actually guest number
11 on this show
uh he is a very very good friend and i
met him quite a few times at
political network offices and and he was
and
in our episode he talked exactly about
what you're saying about you know
relocating to california 2008 crisis but
please go on
yeah slavik is an amazing uh brilliant
entrepreneur um and in uh
we we managed to persevere by the way it
was very difficult i can tell you many
sleepless nights
and in early 2011 we got acquired by
by mcafee and we became the the database
security
solution of mcafee i worked for
mcafee as an executive for a few years
after four years in the bay area i
relocated back with my family to israel
departed from mcafee and in late
2013 the beginning of 2014 i met my
current two partners
both of them are young very ambitious
skillful guys from 8200
from the aram program
and once they finish their military
service they
invented an amazing technology for
identifying evasive attacks
next generation sandbox harnessing new
capabilities of the
intel cpu framework
and we established in early 2014 a cyber
security startup by the name of
hyper-wise security and a year later we
got acquired by
checkpoint and from
2015 until 2019 the three of us have
worked
for checkpoint i was the vp of emerging
products for checkpoint
reporting to to the president of
checkpoint i managed a team of about 200
sales reps and sales engineers
and i was focusing on the advanced
security solutions of checkpoint
namely cloud security mobile security
endpoint security
and advanced threat prevention the next
generation sandbox of checkpoint
by then a product by a family of
products by the name of sandblast
a target of about 300 million dollars a
year
did very well and by the end of 2019 the
three of us we decided to
to depart and to establish
a proper venture capital six months
we dedicated six months to raise funds
for hyperwise ventures and in the
end of february 2020
so almost a year ago we launched the
fund it's a 70 million dollar fund
focusing on early stage sid investments
we want to lead the
seed rounds and since then we made the
five
investments and
we are a very active uh you know looking
for brilliant entrepreneurs to partner
with them to establish amazing startups
focus is on cyber security but also
enterprise software
so obviously we have a very strong
background in cyber security
but we are not limiting ourselves to
only cyber security we do enter proper
enterprise software as well
so a very diverse career spanning more
than
five years uh and again i consider
myself to be very lucky from that
perspective
so nathan even before we do a deeper
dive into
you know these different experiences and
currently what you're doing with hyper
wise vc
tell me a little bit about the cyber
security you know market in general or
the industry
and it's it's a uniquely you know
different i think than than a lot of
other industries
um it's something that is you know
obviously very special to us
uh here in israel and with the
background that we come with but tell me
a little bit about you know how you see
the cyber security world both you know
from
the entrepreneurs perspective of an
early stage company realizing that
there's this gap
there's technological gap and
opportunity to going and you know
creating these companies and that are
acquired by you know by fantastic
companies like checkpoint and mccafe but
also from the investors perspective
understanding okay how does the world
actually look
you know from a bird's eye view on cyber
security and
where are we headed with it
um it's a very good and important
question
because indeed from the outside and you
were
very right in your opening
words saying that from certain
perspective it looks as if there is a
bubble around
cyber security globally and definitely
in israel
but i fully agree with you that the need
for advanced cyber security
is here to stay and definitely is going
to intensify
the cat and mouse race that you were
describing but it's important to stress
out
that the core capabilities around
offensive cyber i mean the bad guys the
the red teams in the last 15 years
is financed by by government
offensive cyber is definitely considered
as a strategic arm
today for nations because of its
amazing effectiveness compared to other
alternatives so today
nations will invest their fortune in
identifying the most brilliant
attackers and to finance core rnd
identifying zero-day vulnerabilities
harnessing them
to breach to hack to create uh
potential damage and so forth uh
a lot of that data and knowledge that is
gained by by governments and nations
will eventually leak to cyber security
criminals
and we will see the effect of that core
knowledge on our day-to-day life
even as consumers definitely as civilian
enterprises and so forth
what i want to now to now ask is this
transition
from entrepreneur to investor so going
from looking at one problem really
deeply
to now you know expanding your reach and
and looking at a variety of problems and
trying to figure out how
they piece together with the
industry of cyber security not just your
solution did you find that transition
you know
difficult easy did you have to change
skill sets in order to do that
so a big portion of my experience uh
was definitely relevant because at the
end of the day
when it when it comes to establishing a
startup
not only the team needs to have a
brilliant idea
and a barrier to entry but at the end of
the day the startup needs
especially in a very competing arena the
startup needs to
execute and excel on the sales and
revenue fronts and this is an
area where i have right a lot of a lot
of experience
from choosing the right go to market for
the startup
moving through establishing an effective
sales operation especially in the u.s
from so from that perspective i
definitely felt that the
experience i have gained as a vp sales
in the united states and in europe and
later
a ceo for at least two cyber security
startups was definitely relevant
but obviously as an investors there are
additional
considerations that you need to take
that as an entrepreneur you don't
always think about the financial aspects
of the
of the investment the ability to
almost guess but it needs to be an
educated guest out of
tens and hundreds of startups ambitious
teams that you meet who is going to be
the the winning team
this is something that uh definitely you
know an experience that i had to uh
we had to to establish so it is both a
combination of past experience being
entrepreneurs ourselves
but also gaining
financial and and investment skills
along the way and this is something that
we touched on
a little bit before we have established
the fund by uh
doing some uh some angel investments
before we have established the funds but
obviously throughout
the the the year that we've been
operating this is something that we have
gained and established quite well
right and how do you then now you look
at a variety of you know
early stage companies you know wanting
to lead seed rounds
and you look at their their technology
with the cyber security
industry are there any patterns that
you're seeing that differentiate between
the ones that you feel more comfortable
partnering with rather than the ones
that you're that you're less comfortable
partnering with yeah i mean
i believe that we've been experiencing
a certain pattern along many
teams of entrepreneurs because on one
hand because of
the the amazing reputation of
the cyber security industry in israel
many
veterans from 8200 and other
technological units you know they are
very eager to establish a startup
however it's very very difficult to
identify
a brilliant idea a real need
and a barrier to entry so many teams
will go through a process which is
called an ideation
but very often they will come up with
what i what we refer to as synthetic
need
so something that from the outside may
look
lucrative but when you dig under the
hood you find out that it doesn't
represent a really need
an urgent need in the market it is more
of a wishful thinking and this is
something that we need to be really
careful about because we invest only
in solutions that solves a real need an
immediate need
that the market indeed needs
and many teams that we met as explained
unfortunately they come
up with those synthetic needs uh
compared to what we would like to invest
in an authentic need
ideally a need that was born throughout
the la the the real life experience of
the entrepreneurs so entrepreneurs that
used to work for a commercial company a
cyber security company for several years
and from their experience and meeting
with customers
of identify a real need this is
something that we look for
or alternatively entrepreneurs that used
to work for a cyber security consulting
company again meeting with the customers
with clients identifying a real need
then coming up with the brilliant
technological solution with a great
barrier to entry
this is something that uh that will be
attractive for us
so again because of the fact that there
is so much demand so many teams would
like to
found and establish a cyber security
startup
we need to that's the phenomena that we
often see
and so then when you go into either do
due diligence or think critically
yourself about it how do you
hope to to find you know real product
market fit in the world of cyber
security
a lot you know mo like 99 percent of
what i'm guessing is you know b2b
and you know you're selling to
enterprises you're offering
similar yet different yet similar
solutions that exist you have to do a
lot of explanations right because a lot
of the times
even though you're selling to perhaps
you know the security people in those
companies
they it's not you know it's not like you
can send them to a landing page
and they sit and look oh yeah this looks
like something i want to buy right it's
not like it's not the same
purchasing experience so so what what
are some struggles there and and what is
the
you know from your experience the right
way to strategically go about
finding that you know product market fit
and whether it's there
it's it's a very good question so it's a
combination of the following first of
all we ourselves
uh uh bring uh many years of uh
of experience uh uh working with real
uh uh customers you know fortune 500
customers across the globe for example
when i was working for checkpoint i was
an executive sponsor for citibank just
as an example so
obviously we bring a lot of intuition
and experience from our own experience
from our own background and experience
coupled with the fact that
our lps the investors of our with our
fund
are a world global leaders in the cyber
security
arena names like ashlomo kremer miki
budai
stuart mcclure and so forth these are
guys that
when we feel that we have the need we
will
we will consult with them and we would
expose the potential startups to them
and look for for their opinion but i
think that the most important
part for us is the startup itself so
ideally we would like to invest in
post-revenue
so a startup that already gained 100 000
200 000 worth of arr we are willing to
pay the toll and
and invest in a higher valuation
in such situation because then we can
really interview the customers that are
using the product
and after three four interviews you can
when you ask the right questions of
course verifying that the product is
really used in the way that
the entrepreneurs were planning it uh to
be used
but if the startup is based on a present
a powerpoint presentation and a good
idea
that doesn't deter us we will ask
and we will help the team to meet and
present the solution to 10 15 20
potential customers and then we will
interview the customers
for us again it is very very important
to identify
that it solves the real need an
immediate need so not a
futuristic need and a a
a significant gap a significant
risk that the startup is going to solve
with a significant technological barrier
to entry
i love it nathan so dang about for for
all the insights your generosity with
your time
i really really appreciate it and i
think what you're doing with hyperwise
vc
uh spinning off of your long time career
as an entrepreneur
engineer and then now i learned a legal
uh you know in the in the legal scene
but so before we leave
i really want to thank you for being
generous with your time and i do have
two really important questions
one of them is the three words that i
always ask but the other one which is
even more important
is what is your favorite beatles song
um probably the the song by george
arizon here comes the sun
i think it is at the end of the day it's
the the most favorite
song even though it's very difficult to
answer that questions it depends on the
mood and how you wake up in the morning
but probably
i remember being in middle school and i
was a beatles fanatic
and i would be listening to the beatles
from morning to night
i think i was the only middle schooler
in israel who was so obsessed with the
beatles and
what i think really it was incredible to
me was both the authenticity behind the
sound
speaking of the cyber security the
authenticity behind the sound
but also the fact that you know for
every mood for every time of the day
there's
one of a thousand songs that you can
choose from that'll be just right
nathan and now i need the three words
uh so i think that the three words that
can describe me are
first of all i'm very devoted to my
family to my friends
and colleagues but definitely to the
entrepreneurs that
we invest in i'm a hard worker i believe
in hard working
and i'm very curious i always like to
learn new things
you know in whatever schools or arenas
or philosophies
i love that nathan stay safe and stay
healthy
and take care bye
[Music]